Europa es un continente que está
envejeciendo a pasos agigantados y es
que se está quedando sin jóvenes según
las estadísticas europeas la oficina de
estadística europea alerta que en 2050
menos del 15% de la población europea
será joven tendrá entre 15 y 29 años
actualmente más de una quinta parte de
la población europea tiene más de 65
años debido al cambio demográfico la
proporción de personas en edad de
trabajar está disminuyendo en cambio los
jóvenes en cambio el de jubilados está
aumentando todo esto según un informe de
la ocd esta Va a provocar mayores
desigualdades porque los jóvenes tendrán
que hacer mayor esfuerzo para pagar las
pensiones Pero en cambio tendrán
trabajos más precarios el envejecimiento
en Europa hay que tener en cuenta que es
multifactorial hay una baja tasa de
fecundidad un declive en la tasa de
mortalidad y una esperanza de vida que
cada vez es mayor esto por lo tanto
también puede un tipo de provocar y
puede tener consecuencias por ejemplo en
también en el papel de Europa en el
mundo y en un mayor declive de su
influencia y Esther Cuál es son los
países más envejecidos particularmente
sí entre los países más envejecidos del
mundo están los europeos al margen de
China e India entre los que destacan
Italia Grecia Portugal bulgar y Alemania
y España pero no solo eso tienen tasas
de fecundidad también muy bajas casi
prácticamente los mismos países destacan
Malta y España con unas tasas de
fecundidad en que no es casual que
ocurra en estos países que les afectó
especialmente por ejemplo la anterior
crisis económica que fue más o menos del
2008 al 2000 2015 son países que en
general tienen poco margen fiscal y por
lo tanto las ayudas a la natalidad y
también a la conciliación laboral han
provocado que las tasas de natalidad y
fecundidad sean tan bajas de hecho
España tiene una tasa de fecundidad de
1,19 hijos esto significa que está por
debajo del 2,1 y por lo tanto la tasa de
envejecimiento cada vez va a ser mayor
para que tengan en cuenta cuando un país
llega a una tasa de alrededor del 1%
es muy difícil que pueda volver a subir
y Esther para terminar Cuáles son las
medidas a nivel europeo que se están
tomando para revertir esta situación
Lo cierto es que la gran mayoría de
medidas que se han tomado son a nivel
nacional porque es una competencia
Nacional para la Unión Europea se está
intentando poner las pilas con medidas
Como por ejemplo para favorecer la
conciliación laboral de hecho se aplicó
recientemente una directiva para que las
mujeres pudieran reincorporarse más
rápido al mercado de trabajo después de
ser madres es una directiva que ha
tenido una buena acogida de hecho
algunos países de hecho incluso la han
ampliado también ha habido medidas para
atraer la migración Como por ejemplo la
conocida como tarjeta azul para atraer
la mano de obra
cualificada proveniente de terceros
países Aunque ha tenido un éxito
bastante desigual estas medidas la Unión
Europea insiste en que hay muchos
factores y que los estados miembros
deben hacer más